entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
il y a plusieurs points de divergences à
commencer par la paix m
la procréation médicalement assistée les
sénateurs sont favorables à l'ouverture
de la pma à toutes les femmes mais pas
pour sa prise en charge par la sécurité
sociale en ce qui concerne les couples
de femmes et les femmes seules
ils souhaitent les sénateurs en effet la
limiter au seul motif médical par
conséquent aux seuls couples
hétérosexuels
je vous propose d'écouter plusieurs
sénateurs il y à une évolution de la
société laquelle on ne peut pas tourner
le dos mais que nous sommes là justement
pour mettre en place ce qu'il faut pour
le permettre mais juste ce qu'il faut et
faire très très attention aux dérives
qu'il pourrait y avoir donc c'est
vraiment le rôle au sein de cette
commission spéciale de bioéthique du
sénat que nous avons souhaité c'est à
dire mettre des limites et des barrières
sans pour autant être rétrogradé et en
permettant toutefois ces évolutions que
l'on constate malgré tout et qui sont
indéniables non il ne fait pas
l'unanimité auprès des deux chambres il
ne fait pas l'unanimité au sein des
chambres à elle-même ce qui est normal
c'est un projet de loi qui est un projet
de société et il n'y avait pas unanimité
dans la société non plus lorsque les
débats généraux de la bioéthique ont eu
lieu avant l'établissement du projet de
loi c'est une aventure collective on
voit bien que ce qui était un mode il ya
50 ans ne l'est plus aujourd'hui
réciproquement mais pourtant c'est de
pas faire de dégâts humains que
on a des moyens aujourd'hui de répondre
à beaucoup de questions notamment une
fertilité donc je pense que c'est une
bonne chose et ce qui m'effraie 7 est
pugnace it et de hargne avec laquelle
les gens sont content je respecte le
fait qu'il soit contre mais je vous
cache pas que si j'ai dit et je bascule
de notre côté c'est à dire au jeu bien
plus milito répond que ça soit possible
la réforme de la filiation doit aussi
être débattue ici au palais bourbon avec
un nouveau mode pour les enfants de
couples de femmes la filiation sera
établie à l'égard de la femme qui a
accouché via sa désignation dans l'acte
de naissance tandis que celle qui n'a
pas porté le bébé le sera par la
reconnaissance conjointe
en revanche les sénateurs ont réécrit
l'article concernant la filiation d'un
enfant né à l'étranger d'une gpa
gestation pour autrui une pratique
interdite en france
les sénateurs devraient aussi discuter
de l'accès aux origines des enfants nés
d'un don de gamètes donc ovules ou aux
spermatozoïdes les textes prévoient et
qu'il puisse en effet accéder à leur
majorité à des informations personnelles
voire à l'identité complète du donneur
sur le volet recherche les sénateurs
avaient interdit en commission la
création d'embryons transgéniques et
chimirec ainsi que tout acte toute
techniques de modification les débats
vont durer trois jours ici et si les
sénateurs modifie à nouveau le texte des
élus des deux chambres donc sénat et
assemblée nationale devront se retrouver
en commission mixte paritaire pour
tenter de trouver un compromis mais il
faut savoir et bien que le dernier mot
reviendra à l'assemblée nationale en cas
de désaccord persistant